Well, my biggest hope is in fact that
there is a future to the Arctic.
As it looks now we are changing the Arctic
in such a fundamental way that perhaps
what we once considered the Arctic; as a far removed place that it would be difficult to get to is changing.
The Arctic may in fact become a very easy and accessible place to go to. But then it would no longer be
the Arctic - it actually would be a melting Arctic - and it would change fundamentally the way we look
at the world, and the way the world would appear to us because the temperature of the world would rise
so much that the whole structure and infrastructure and ecosystem of the world would change.
I often say that when I think about the word 'future'
I think about the poet
- the 20th century French poet Paul Valéry -
who said: "The future isn't what it used
to be" and it strikes me that the future
of the Arctic is in our hands and we can
probably reverse the way in which the
Arctic is being destroyed by being
actively engaged in social change.